you uh
getting beanie on the
project had i mean beanie timmy is
probably like top three or four
most slept on rappers ever when we think
about just the respect that like we
don't talk about beanie like i think we
should and you know as far as being an
all-time great
um i think he's in those conversations
um they
uh
that was one of the features that i
didn't hear when you played me the album
so i'm assuming that was something that
probably happened in the last i don't
know what 12 months or something yeah
that happened that happened pretty
recently
things kind of buffalo and you know
sandwiches you know beans in buffalo
yeah you kind of buffalo and
you know kind of getting next to me and
[ __ ] and like y'all came to come [ __ ]
with you [ __ ] you know what i'm saying
like
[Music]
and we had some some very very
very dope conversations man you know the
stuff that
you know he wanted to come to buffalo
and just
the conversations he wanted to have with
me that you know i'm gonna talk about
right uh on camera and [ __ ] but
he's been through a lot man though man
yeah just dope that he came to me for
that
you know what i'm saying it's different
when someone comes to you especially in
your hometown you know what i mean
that's different you could link up with
someone in atlanta or l.a that's easy
but like someone coming to buffalo
security and none of that [ __ ] like just
on some regular [ __ ] just having this
man
how long was he in buffalo a couple days
ah yeah for like a week oh [ __ ] so he
tapped in oh he was cooking we knocked a
few shits out wow that's what i'm saying
like we we we about to we we got some
something up our sleeve so hey wait hold
on
conway beanie project
more
border that
more than that
hmm
conway on is are you bringing beanie to
drum work
well i'll see all right this is this
beanie seagull on drum work
i don't know man you know i don't know
i don't know what the future but you
know we've been cooking you know what i
was saying we've been cooking i love
beanie
i would say to him
yo man
you're independent now
he really
being the goat that he is he just got to
run up his his [ __ ] now because i feel
like finally like you know he's having a
moment right now like yeah
you know i saw him in with game yeah
that's what i was telling him like
i heard some [ __ ] um